ist andrea kalb andreas kalbitz wenn man
von byern höcker als dem kopf oder dem
gesicht des fürsprechern sind sie der
sogenannten strippenzieher gelten als
sehr in der partei sind auch beisitzer
im bundesvorstand der afg treten dafür
auch wieder an
er wird sie fordern mehr einfluss für
den flügel in der partei auch mit dem
hinweise auf die wahlerfolge in
ostdeutschland was stellen sie sich
eigentlich vor wie sollte die partei
sich ändern was muss an ihr geändert
werden also erstmal ist das so nicht
korrekt wir fordern nicht oder ich
fordern nicht als flügel mehr einfluss
in der partei das ist falsch sondern wir
denken dass durch die wahl erfolge im
osten auch die ostdeutsche länder
angemessen abgebildet werden sollen das
entscheiden schlussendlich natürlich die
led delegierten
hier geht es nicht um flügel nicht
flügel hier geht es darum dass wir einen
vernünftigen ausgleich finden und das
ist das wofür ich mich einsetze und
hoffe dass das auch angenommen wird
was würden sie denn jetzt anders machen
wollen in der partei was stört sie
vielleicht an dem was die fdp bisher
gemacht hat sie haben das ja auch
kritisiert ich habe das gar nicht
kritisiert was die afc bisher gemacht
hat dass es auch falsch
es geht auch nicht darum was anders zu
machen das geht darum dass wir uns
konsolidieren wie stellen wir uns
strukturell tragfähige auf
schlagkräftige auf das ist ganz wichtig
strategisch stehen wichtige wahlen im
westen vor uns 20 21 da wird man auch
nicht mit patentrezepten aus dem osten
das komplett bewältigen können also ich
sehe das wesentlich differenzierter
es geht darum natürlich kurs zu halten
für die afg wir haben im osten damit
große erfolge generiert das wollen wir
auch im westen wir wissen wir sind nur
im bund stark und das ist unser
gemeinsames ziel und dafür stehe auch
ich dafür steht auch der flügel
es geht nicht um strömungen die
gegeneinander arbeiten sondern es geht
auch ein ausgleich zu finden um
miteinander erfolg zu haben
aber es gibt ja hier auch strömungen der
partei die eigentlich einen größeren
einfluss des flügels jetzt gerade auch
bei den wahlen zum bundesvorstand
verhindern wollen weil sie ihnen zu
rechts national zu völkisch sind was
haben sie da also
rechts kann man sein im demokratischen
sinne völkisch ist der flügel sicher
nicht das ist unsinn
das ist ja auch ein etikett das medial
aufoktroyiert wurde das haben sie noch
nie von uns von mir oder vom dialekt
gehört dass es die das ist eine ganz
andere frage
natürlich kann man diskutieren über
ausrichtungen natürlich kann man
diskutieren über einzelne aspekte
aber ich denke das ist eine große grund
klammer gibt mit dem ft
grundsatzprogramm das uns vereint das
betrifft sowohl den flügel der nur lose
interessengemeinschaft ist in der partei
als auch alle anderen in der afd
und ich glaube dass solche parteitag
dazu angetan sind so ein ausweis zu
finden gut also was diesen diese
titulierung oder dieses etikett
deutschnational oder rechts national
völkische angeht da geht es ja auch um
äußerungen die ja aus der richtung des
flügels kommen deutschland den deutschen
viel zu viele ausländer in deutschland
raus aus der europäischen union vielmehr
nationalstaat das ist ja eigentlich das
was da kritisiert wird es sind das alles
punkte die sie für richtig halten
nein das ist natürlich falsch zum teil
was sie sagen das muss man
differenzieren kein mensch in der afd
oder auch nicht im flügel sagt pauschal
ausländer raus das ist ja unsinn ja wir
werden uns gegen unkontrollierte
zuwanderung in die sozialsysteme
das ist völlig richtig differenzieren
ist aber sehr genau dass wir sagen all
die menschen mit migrationshintergrund
die schon sehr lange her sind die hier
leben arbeiten sich integriert haben die
gehören natürlich zu diesem land
insofern ist das ja eine npd parole die
wir völlig ablehnen
das zu sagen ja wir sind kritisch
gegenüber der eu wir glauben die eu ist
undemokratisch aufgestellt also das muss
man differenziert betrachten und deshalb
stimmen diese thesen zu sagen wie
ausländer raus ist falsch dafür steht
niemand in der ard und auch nicht der
flügel gut also nur was die überfremdung
angeht
etwa ein viertel der deutschen meinen es
gäbe zu viele ausländer insgesamt aber
fast 90 prozent der fdp wähler tun dass
also müssen sie ja auch deren
erwartungshaltung bedienen dass
deutschland überfremdet ist es geht mir
nicht darum erwartungshaltung zu
bedienen sondern probleme zu erkennen
die wir politisch haben und wir haben
ein problem mit den folgender
unkontrollierten zuwanderung das ist ja
ersichtlich schauen sich die letzte
kriminalstatistik des
bundeskriminalamtes an
das sind ganz klare und nüchterne zahlen
man muss über diese probleme offen
diskutieren dürfen ohne dass er sofort
ein etikett aufgedrückt wird ich glaube
das ist das problem das wir haben und
wie frank walter steinmeier immer so
schön gesagt hat man sollte wieder
diskutieren können ohne schaum vom mund
was sagen sie zu den vorwürfen dass sie
bevor sie bei der afg waren in einer
rechtsextremistischen organisation
mitglied fahren bei der jungen
landsmannschaft ostpreußen das haben sie
ja auch gegenüber ihrem damaligen
arbeitgeber bundeswehr zugegeben und
hätten es angeblich auch nicht angegeben
als sie bei der afg eingetreten sind
haben sie eigentlich gegen die
parteisatzung verstoßen
wenn sie jetzt sagen sie sind nicht
rechts national sie sind nicht völlig
wie passt das dann mit ihrer politischen
vergangenheit zusammen
ich denke durchaus dass sich rechts
national im strengen demokratischen
sinne bin aber nicht völkisch und da
wird natürlich vieles vermengt was nicht
zusammengehört eines ist doch klar ich
war zwölf jahre soldat bei der
bundeswehr und ja es gab ganz normale
sondierungsgespräche die der
militärische abschirmdienst mit 1
soldaten führt sie zum beispiel in
sicherheitsrelevanten bereichen
eingesetzt sind offensichtlich kam der
amadea zu dem schluss dass es keinerlei
maßnahmen gibt die erforderlich sind
insofern habe ich alles und
demokratisches gütesiegel
so kann man das aushält ich habe ein
dienst regulär beendet habe betreue
diesem land mit einem wald auf die
verfassung gedient und das ist was
vordergründig der fall ist und was der
medial vermengt wird ist tappen mischung
aus fakten und fake als bundeswehrsoldat
mussten sicher die bundesrepublik
deutschland und auch das grundgesetz
verteidigen
das ist für sie auch nach wie vor
verteidigungsminister standlicht steht
fest auf dem boden der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung sonst hätte
ich nicht zwölf jahren leben und
gesundheit eingesetzt für dieses land
für diese stadt und für diese
gesellschaft warum gibt es dann auch in
der afg unter den sogenannten gemäßigten
viele die sagen also dass ein
durchmarsch flügel zu verhindern weil
das
schade dem ansehen der partei und
möglicherweise bedeutet das ja auch eine
beobachtung durch den verfassungsschutz
also es geht hier nicht um den
durchmarsch des flügels deshalb gehöre
auch klar gestellt es geht darum den 5
den ausgleich zu finden das ist ganz
klar wir arbeiten gemeinsam daran die
haltlosen vorwürfe des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz der zunehmend
politisch instrumentalisiert wird ja
inzwischen mehren etablierten schutz ist
als den verfassungsschutz das zu
entkräften da arbeiten wir auch
gemeinsam dran und ich bin
zuversichtlich das hat ja auch das
gerichtsurteil gezeigt wo eben nicht
mehr behauptet werden darf die afg ist
ein prüfer nach außen das zu entkräften
und server gemeinsamen tun als gesamter
dass wir als partei auch einen
staatsrechtler beauftragt ein gutachten
gesagt hat die afg politiker die
verbrennen sich viel zu oft den mund mit
völkischen mit rechtsextremistischen
äußerungen
also ich lieber offen wie sich das wort
völkisch als etikett wenn man versuchen
das so bis hin zu setzen als negativ das
trifft einfach nicht zu in der sache ja
da mögen unbedachte äußerungen dabei
gewesen sein
die natürlich auch dem umstand
geschuldet sind dass der eine oder
andere noch nicht so lange im
politischen betrieb ist und ja es gibt
pointierte aussagen durchaus auch von
mir dir aber auf keinen fall irgendwie
ernsthaft dazu angetan sind die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
in frage zu stellen das tun wir nicht
dass es nicht unser bestreben die wir
sind teil dieser demokratie wir stellen
uns zur wahl wir anerkennen die regeln
uns geht es nicht um ein system umsturz
es geht nicht um die abschaffung der
gewaltenteilung es geht nicht um die
infragestellung der menschenrechte dass
es unsinn und ich glaube da geht es viel
um instrumentalisierung im politischen
kampf auch bei gegnern vielleicht
manchmal sogar innerparteilich das ist
bedauerlich dass nämlich aber als breite
stimme nicht war in der partei
ich will jetzt gar keine narrativ setzen
sondern einfach nur darauf hinweisen
umfragen sagen dass ja dass zb ein
großteil der afg wälder sagen unter die
deutsche geschichte in 133 45 soll der
ein schlussstrich gezogen werden
sind sie das auch so es geht nicht um
ein schlussstrich dergestalt dass wir
sagen wir stehen nicht zu der
verantwortung die sich aus den
schrecklichen verbrechen des
nationalsozialismus ergibt zu dieser
verantwortung stehen wir auch das ist
gar keine frage
ich denke dass der fokus auf die
vergangenheit gar nicht die maßgebliche
rolle spielt für die herausforderung die
wir politisch haben wir haben
ein hehl daraus gemacht dass wir in der
tradition auch der erinnerungskultur
stehen dergestalt dass man sagt das ist
teil unserer geschichte
aber es ist eben ein teil der geschichte
und es ist nicht die ganze geschichte
das zeigt auch ein blick in die
geschichtsbücher das ist ja keine frage
der persönlichen politischen haltung und
ja das muss man aussprechen können wenn
das so ist es geht nicht darum irgend
was zu verharmlosen oder gar zu leugnen
das werden sie nicht finden
und wer sowas leugnet auch verbrechen
leugnet oder verharmlost er hat auch
kein platzen auf dem